alan dershowitz professor i'm going to
start with you I read your column I
almost read the whole thing on radio
today you have tried up until today when
we've had much disagreement on this to
defend Muller to respect the process
even though we all know that under
article 2 the president always had the
authority to fire him for conflicts etc
he would have just been replaced
very few people seem to point that out
what did you see today that changed your
mind what I saw today was him putting
his thumb his elbow on the scale when he
said quote if we had had confidence that
the president clearly did not commit a
crime we would have said so that was
absolutely inappropriate for him to say
it was worse than anything that Comey
said when he exonerated Hillary Clinton
and then said but she engaged in
extremely careless conduct everybody
condemned that this is much much worse
and it does show that he had a motive to
help the Democrats here there's no other
possible motive why he would have gone
out of his way to say that he could have
easily said the opposite if we had
confidence that the president didn't
commit a crime we would have said it if
we had confidence that he committed a
crime we would have said it but no we
emphasized only the possibility the
president might have committed a crime
that went well beyond his authority of
special counsel it also showed we never
should have had a special counsel we
should have had an objective neutral
nonpartisan investigative Commission
looking into the entire effort of Russia
to intrude itself into the 16 election
and continuing to the 20 election and
proposing efforts to ameliorate that in
the future a special counsel was a
terrible terrible mistake and I think
Muller statement today proves that
beyond any doubt